I want to welcome everyone to our weekly
conference most of you are regular
attendees which is good but some of our
conferences we designate as ID l talks
and I think most of you know I dl stands
for the informatics discovery lab which
is this initiative in the department to
try to branch out expand our horizons a
little bit in the form of collaborations
with industry and other shall we say
non-traditional at least for us partners
and so this is the first IDL talk of the
academic year and we happen to have a
speaker whose local entrepreneur and one
of the other goals of the IDL is to
promote local interactions with industry
for the for the benefit of all so our
speaker today is dr. ray constantini
who's a physician and he is recently
left his prior job at providence health
and services where he was medical
director and director of their digital
product strategy now he has gone off
into the wild Wow yonder of startup
companies and he's going to tell us
about his work with his company bright
md just by background he received his
bachelor's degree and MD from the
University of Arizona and he also has an
MBA from the Thunderbird Thunderbird
school of international business
fantastic well I'm thrilled to have so
many people here I was just telling
Aaron I was kind of hoping there'd be
like two of you and I wouldn't have any
pressure on me but we'll see what we can
do it to make this work I also heard
that I have a captive audience and that
some of you guys have to be there
because this is class work which is
awesome I love it that makes it that
much less pressure for me too I
definitely remember getting lectures
from
and I would rather have this not via
lecture and have it be interactive you
guys have questions I would much rather
know what you guys want to hear about
and talk to that that stand up here and
try and guess and and do that I
definitely have some stuff i'll go
through to kind of set the stage but
jump right in throw up your hands or a
tweet i think is how we're getting
questions from folks from from elsewhere
yeah so please make my job easier and
ask me lots of questions it'll be
fantastic but as bill said i am ray
costantini i'm a physician i am now a
four-time entrepreneur I've done this a
couple of times which means that I am
certifiably nuts and we'll talk about
more about that and entrepreneurship a
little bit later but the first thing I
thought that might be helpful the idea
of this talk was to talk about
transforming healthcare and how
entrepreneurship can play a role in that
and in order to talk about that the
first thing I thought would be
worthwhile we to talk about health care
itself and actually a really interesting
conversation with Bhumi before the
before the lecture today and we're
talking about defining things and how
important it is in order to be able to
change something they say you have to be
able to measure it I think that's very
real if you can't measure something you
can't change it if you are changing you
don't know whether you have but nor to
be able to do that first you have to be
able to define it and for a long time in
healthcare I think we were without that
compass in terms of what is it that
we're really striving for we would look
at pieces of it which are incredibly
important as well and we would make
progress in each of those directions but
more recently there's been I think
personally a really fantastic compass
which is that Triple Aim and I think
about this slightly differently than
I've seen other people talk about it
it's probably my quantitative brain I
think about it as a formula you think
about outcomes and you think about
experience and you think about per
capita costs which I think probably all
of you guys have heard about in terms of
Triple Aim anybody who has not heard
about Triple Aim in terms of value
perfect yeah raise your hands that's
totally okay that's why I'm asking so
this is actually so the IHI was really
the place where this kind of developed
and it's really a fantastic way to think
about it and to be honest this doesn't
just apply the health care
it's just funny because it's applied to
lots of other industries all other
industries but health care didn't really
think its teeth into it and think about
in themselves that same way so the idea
here is in order to meet that Triple Aim
in order to be able to make health care
better we want to improve outcomes and
we want to improve experience and we
want to drive down costs and I mean
that's pretty sensible you do that in
almost any other industry as well the
interesting thing to think about though
is that it really is a ratio and what
you're trying to do is maximize that
ratio you want to make it as as big of a
number if you plug those numbers in
somehow as possible so if you raise
quality outcomes you know that first
piece through the roof just crazy
fantastic outcomes but you raised per
capita costs at an equal amount you
haven't optimized that ratio it's really
about being able to create those things
in relationship to each other and so
with that in mind and defining that
again as what healthcare value looks
like well as a starting point we could
have whole conversations about that as
well let's go through some of those
pieces particularly for the US
healthcare system so we spend the most
we're going to start with the
denominator here I mean by far and away
the United States spends more than any
other country in the world and this is
on a per capita basis now if you turn
this from a per capita basis into total
spend United States spends two to three
times more than any other developed
country in the world on our health care
so you can see that we're number one
we're we're really good at that we spend
a ton of money on healthcare now our
quality rankings so the wh 0 went
through and did quality rankings on
healthcare systems across the world I
did a ton of countries and number one
was France they did a fantastic job
great score 994 Japan UK all them have
fantastic systems now you notice the
United States is not in those top three
in fact it is number 38 in the world it
is below every other developed country
in the world in fact is below dominica
and just above Slovenia who incidentally
spend a tiny tiny fraction of the amount
of money that we do on health care now
to put this into a business context
we're getting a really crappy return on
our investment we're putting in a ton of
money and we're not getting outcomes on
the outside to show that we're not
getting experience well that's another
piece let's talk about that so we think
about that ratio again we just talked
about spend we just talked a little bit
about quality and they included a number
of endpoint metrics in here including
including longevity maternal fetal
mortality quality of life access to care
that was all included in that quality
piece of it but now about experience of
care and the truth of the matter is
nobody is getting a great experience of
care in the United States either it's
not like we have kind of mediocre
quality we're spending a ton of money
but the experience is just extraordinary
that's not really true and we tell
ourselves at some times we talk about oh
well those Canadians they wait forever
for health care guess what this is the
United States this is primary care
access right now it's terrible in fact
it's true Canada is worse than we are
but they are the only developed country
in the world who has worse primary care
access than the United States does and
in fact they're getting better we're
getting worse that is not a good trend
line there and you can see this is
miserable I mean the best of the best is
days that you're waiting and that's like
one major metropolitan area you're
talking about weeks to months look at
Boston over there 66 days to be able to
get primary care access that's miserable
I mean that's really not and we're
spending a ton of money to be able to do
that and the question then is why and
here's a big part of the reason why for
that particular setting so now we're
kind of trying to drill in a little bit
around one particular subset of care I
will talk about primary care 50 minutes
why is primary care access so difficult
this is a big part of it we have an
exploding patient demand we have an
aging population we have a growing
population we have new legislation
that's pushing the really sick people
didn't use to get primary care they've
got this huge pent-up demand into the
system now and so they're consuming not
only a one more person's worth of health
care services but you know a pent-up
demand of years of service incidentally
we are also the only country in the
world that only developed country in the
world that does not still have universal
health care coverage so another issue
around there around both experience and
quality and so we have started pushing
more of those people into the system and
that's making it worse and then we have
this provider supply issue where it
takes years to train new primary care
providers and then you got to convince
them to go into primary care which is
not an easy thing to be able to do
either when you're coming in under a
bunch of debt and there are other places
where you can make more money and have a
better lifestyle really have that kind
of a passion for primary care to go into
that now the other thing is that even
once you go into primary care it's hard
for docs to you know we talk about that
experience of care for patients but what
about the experience of care for
providers as well and this is something
I had a lot of conversation people about
I don't want to imply that providers are
the reason for health care they are part
of the to put it in business terms
provided a part of the supply chain they
are there an input into the overall
healthcare delivery process they're an
incredibly important piece of that but
patients are our customers they are the
people who we are here to serve that's
what healthcare is for is to make
patients better but the truth of the
matter is we have to be think about this
as well in primary care is hard for docs
as well we're seeing declining margins
are making less money they're being
asked to do much much more for a lot
less as well you know we started to
where you know not that long ago you see
10 12 13 patients a day now in 15 and
then 17 and then 19 and then 20 and now
22 when we're hearing from delivery
systems that they expect their primary
care providers to get up to 25 patients
per day or more that's that's a lot of
churn you put them on a treadmill and
you turn up the speed and you vlog them
a little bit if they don't go fast
enough and that's kind of the process
we've gotten into on top of that you get
these new business models you guys are
probably familiar with the Affordable
Care
than some of the moves towards
value-based care as compared to p /
service does that sound familiar to
anybody anybody doesn't sound familiar
with everybody's on everybody you guys
get the idea of moving to a kind of a
capitated system okay good that's
actually huge piece so understanding how
that stuff works is a really important
part of thinking about how is healthcare
going to get reshaped it's it's a really
intrinsic part of the future of
healthcare so the question is we've got
this broken system where there's not a
good experience there's ton of money
getting spent and quality is not
matching with what we would expect given
those inputs what is that well oops
wrong button you guys already saw that
one so what does it take to have a
really efficient system what makes any
industry run smoothly there's three
things that you really need and we could
spend hours talking mrs. economics I
mean we could spend hours talking with
this on itself but in the end three big
buckets of things that you need in order
to be able to make any industry or
system work really smoothly one of them
is competing suppliers you have to have
multiple people saying we want to
provide a service right and then you
need engage customers who want that
service and are interested in what makes
one of these suppliers better or worse
than another whether that's price or
quality or experience or you know
there's there's a ton of things that you
can differentiate around but that's
really you know those are two really
important pieces but then in order to
let those two folks interact you need
that third piece which is transparency
so you've got customers who are
interested in the things that these
suppliers are competing to provide and
provide better than each other right but
you have to be able to know about those
differences we don't have any of those
not one of those three things as
healthcare have and this is really
interesting I mean you think about
competing suppliers we really don't I
mean in a lot of markets this is some
place you've got a single hospital and
you've got a single insurer who makes up
the vast majority of the market so there
isn't a lot of competition in that space
you have engaged customers well
times but I would say that's at best you
think about how much time somebody
spends shopping for a car and
researching with you whether you're
going to buy a Prius or a Ford Focus
people put in a bunch of time around
that you don't put anywhere near that
amount of time into researching which
provider they go see or what should they
do for their low back pain and we can
talk a whole bunch about why that is
it's not necessarily because consumers
aren't interested maybe because they
don't have that third piece as well
which is that transparency the ability
to be able to see those where would you
go even if you wanted to know about how
much something costs or the quality of
the services that you'd be getting I
mean if you want to know about a Prius
versus a Ford Focus you go and consumer
reports and you can do some research you
get that information you can look at the
cost and you can shop around you can't
do that in health care there's just the
heart the resources available to make
that happen so that is really what we
have is we have a system where none of
those pieces are there they're all
missing and so what we have is a really
rusted inefficient system where it's
difficult to make things better there
isn't that competition or that
transparency or that engagement to drive
that forward and it's tough but it also
means that there's a lot of opportunity
to make things better and we'll get to
that in a little bit when we talk about
entrepreneurship also but there's also a
question about why why else why you know
we talked about the difference between
value-based the care versus
fee-for-service right you guys are
pretty involved in health care how many
of you guys see fee-for-service is just
like it's the wave of the future you
know we are going to continue doing fee
for service and good that's anybody be
brave I mean it's okay if you think it's
a good conversation to have I'll run
into people sometimes to do with it's
totally alright alright any any tweets
okay so about that one we all know that
this is moving forward we all know
they're in a shift from this model of do
something submit a bill get paid broken
system I mean this is like really talked
a bunch about why that system is broken
as well talk about incentives and bro
and incentive systems and oh god you
know what is that in sent if we've got a
fee-for-service setting where I do
something I submit a bill and I get
reimbursement period and that largely
encompasses what a fee for services with
some nuances in there but largely that's
it what is that what is that in scent
and incense filling hospital beds that's
what it in sense it makes hospital it
makes hospitals and delivery systems it
makes them into a system that is
rewarded for filling hospital beds
rather than keeping people well and
that's really unfortunate unfortunately
we're in an industry that's full of
people who want to do good so despite
the fact that we've got this broken
incentive system we still have a ton of
people out there who really do want to
do the right thing and they'll do it in
spite of the fact that they're being
disincentive around it I mean no good
deed goes unpunished in a delivery
system under a fee-for-service setting
you're a fantastic primary care provider
and you decide that you are going to
hire more staff to help you better
manage diabetes you're diabetic patients
yeah and you go out and you find a
diabetic educator and a social worker
and I got a patient navigator and you
bring them into your practice and you
pay them to do that and you make all
your patients better you can't build for
it you get really i mean if you get for
any of this pc if you built for him
you're building in a much lower rate and
you can't really make that financially
it doesn't work and the other problem is
on top of that how you've made your
patients healthier which means they're
not coming back to see you so not only
are you spending more money you're
making less money too I mean that's
terrible I mean that's that's really
really broken so but and everybody knows
this and the question is why aren't we
why aren't we changing why are we saying
okay we know this is broken and
everybody knows it's broken and we we
know where we're going we see this
future point why why aren't we changing
faster i'm going to tell you guys a
story i have four kids by the way and
and I I like to tell them stories and
this is when I like to tell it's
Cinderella that you guys have all heard
the story of Cinderella I'm going to go
a slightly modified version here but
really in some ways
health care is really in a similar boat
to Cinderella you know I mean Cinderella
goes to the ball right she knows that at
midnight it's going to hit the fan she's
got to get out of there right and what's
she going to do was the first thing you
do when you come into the room if you're
Cinderella you find a clock on the wall
right you're like I need to know what
time it is because you know when it gets
to be midnight we got a I got to be
doing something a little bit differently
and that really is it's the same thing
as our US health care system but the the
problem is that there isn't a cloth on
the wall for the health care system to
be looking at you know we argue about
what time it is you know we know that at
some point we're going to move to the
steeper service environment and that's
when the clock strikes midnight and
everybody knows that they're going to
have to get out of the party right but
what time is it is it 1155 is it 930 you
know it's coming and everyone knows the
clock is ticking but we don't really
know what time it is so we spend a bunch
of time arguing about what time it is
the other difference is that unlike
Cinderella so Cinderella she's chinos
come midnight everybody else is going to
keep doing their own thing and she can
kind of sneak out the back door and it's
not a big deal for her the special
things right the difference here is when
the party end everybody's got to leave
at the same time and there's there's a
there's a mess you know and i think i'm
skipping some of my slides here so
forgive me i'm going to jump ahead on a
couple of these they're pretty pictures
but i think you guys are getting the
story anyways literally don't we have
that broken we have that broken clock
and for Cinderella the problem here is
not only a four for her she can get out
but for health care not only do we not
know what time it is and not only do we
realize everybody's got a lead when the
clock finally rings what happens it's
not going to be some nice orderly exit
where everybody files out of the
ballroom it's more like a fire at a rock
concert right I mean you think about
this all of a sudden the bells ringing
every is like oh my god everything's
changing we all know it's time to go
that's scary and the thing that happens
is that people get trampled there are
mortality
in that process you know I mean there
are actually predictions out there that
thirty percent of hospitals will be
shuttered by 2025 because of this same
thing because we were you know if we if
we actually successfully move from a
heads in beds business model of making
money by having people who are sick get
treated in hospitals to a model where
we're incentive to keep people well
that's a big change and there have to be
casualties in that process the question
is who's going to successfully get out
of the building and who's going to get
burned in the fire and who's going to
get trampled to death on the way out the
door it's a little messy and so that's
that's really the question but so same
thing this all sounds scary like well
god why am I not standing by the door
you know and that's that's the real
question and the answer is as we've been
dancing around you get this health care
Cinderella dancing around the ball she's
developed a really big appetite you
think about all those hospitals and
there's a huge capital investment that's
gone into those hospitals and those
clinics and the delivery systems and the
imaging equipment and the staff and
everything that goes into that it's
there and it just it's hungry all the
time as we're dancing around we've got
that appetite and the thing is as we
start moving towards the door imagine on
one side of the ballroom there's the
exit right and on the other side of the
ballroom there's a cake table and you're
hungry right which side of the ballroom
do you want to be on you know that at
some point you know the bells going to
ring the fire is going and you got to
get out the door but you're hungry still
and you think we're good at eating cake
you know I mean that's the truth of the
matters we're really good at he didn't
cake and when I step away from the door
oh but when I step away from the table
over there and I step towards the door
every step a way that I take makes me
hungrier because I can't get the cake
and that's a big part of what keeps us
from moving forward around this and why
we have these delivery systems so I'll
pause for a second here because I'm
going to shift gears that kind of
means an ugly picture of where we're at
and I don't want to be all doom and
gloom but i do want to pause for a
second there's a sunnier side for this
whole thing I promise any questions or
thoughts at this point from you guys I
know I'm not that informative well fair
enough the next thing I was going to do
is going to talk about entrepreneurship
a little bit as well as I do think that
is truly that mean it's it's a it's a
messy space wing but the neat thing
about entrepreneurship is well I had
somebody tell me once I tried to put
together a good slide around this and I
couldn't think of a great way I was told
once that there is a Chinese character
for adversity and it is incredibly
similar to the Chinese character for
opportunity I don't think it's actually
true the characters but I do think that
the sentiment behind everybody thinks
the Chinese characters say everything
that's why people get those crazy
tattoos that don't mean what they really
met them say but but I mean in the end I
think that really the concept behind
that is very true and it is a question
of perception of how are you frame is
how you approach this all of that that
we just talked about it is a terrible
adversity which means that we're in an
incredibly target-rich environment you
can swing a stick and help make health
care better I mean it's awesome that's
so cool and so with that I'm going to
transition a little bit into kind of how
I owe ya before we get into
entrepreneurship as the answer what are
your opinions of federal policy do we
have the attention span to move from a
fee for her fee for service system yeah
so what role are saying what role does
the federal government help in making
that happen yeah yeah I mean I think so
i think large established organizations
established companies have a tremendous
amount of inertia and that's not in
health care that's just period that's
just the way that business works you
know I mean we're you know businesses
started snowballs as a non trip every
business starts as an entrepreneurial
venture every single one of them and
they start as these nimble little
snowballs that can adjust
then move around in their environment
and they start to build inertia and they
keep moving in the same direction and
eventually they kind of become glaciers
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
either in a stable environment and it
where the landscape is pretty steady it
glaciers carve continents they're
incredibly powerful and useful to be
able to do that you know there's a lot
of power in that inertia but once the
environment starts changing that's tough
now the federal government there they
can help with those things I think we're
seeing some of those pieces they're
incredibly motivated that's the
interesting thing twenty percent of GDP
almost twenty percent now and it will be
twenty percent very shortly it's spent
on health care if we don't fix that and
will end on top of that hold on not just
twenty percent of GDP gets spent on
health care which is more than any other
industry substantially more than any
other industry or piece of hell of spend
in the United States there is nothing
that even comes close to touching that
and it's growing at twice the rate of
inflation so you're spending way more
and the rate of spin is increasing
exponentially that's scary I think
Greece and and that's what policymakers
in the federal government are thinking
about right now is that we will be
crushed under the cost of our health
care as a company we will be greased if
we can't fix that now the challenge on
the federal side is they do it in short
stretches and their job and I'm going to
be a little they need to make sure that
whatever they've done works in the
four-year span that it takes for them to
get reelected rather than over the
longer term so i think that there's a
balancing act i don't think that they're
the answer but i think that they're an
important component that it fair okay
perfect so entrepreneurship my wife
likes to tease with me I think she's
teasing and she asked me what's the
difference between being an entrepreneur
and being unemployed
that's the end of the joke that's the
whole thing uh no III she is she's
generally kidding when she says that
there's definitely a difference and it's
tough I mean I can't lie to I will not
paint you an overly sunny picture of
entrepreneurship it's very exciting
there are a bunch of reasons that i can
tell you why to go into it how many
people here are have started a business
oh good okay we get some hands okay uh
yeah yeah no it's good yeah depends on
what you define as a business many
people would consider this department of
business you know what I I think it's a
great point and actually when I was the
provenance we started the department we
called it intrapreneurship and it is
different but there are tremendous
amount of similarities and bringing some
of the same entrepreneurial skills and
add mindsets to bear in these large
established organizations can be a huge
challenge you know try spinning
snowballs off of a glacier it definitely
it takes work and it's a but it's a very
very powerful thing to be able to do as
well so I I agree completely so don't
I'm going to give you a couple of don'ts
first don't become an entrepreneur
because you don't want to have a boss
bad idea because it doesn't work that
way I should have asked are there any
investors in the room no I'm teasing
here i will say honestly investors can
be a fantastic partner as well but the
truth of the matter is i say this in
jest but you don't get away with not
having a boss anywhere when you form a
company you you are serving the needs of
others if you want to have a successful
business that's what your job is and if
you don't have a board and you don't or
you don't have investors you've got
clients they're your boss in the end and
i think that is a really important thing
to met don't go into entrepreneurship
because it because of that well what
what is so what is entrepreneurship what
what is the difference between being
unemployed and being an entrepreneur
part of it is an endless curiosity being
really interested in exploring and
wanting to explore and that's a huge
piece of entrepreneurs and good at that
they asked questions and even
more importantly than asking the
questions is they listen and that's
really important but on top of that and
I think who was I surprised I think we
were talking about this you know it's
not just listening though entrepreneurs
also you need to be able to take that
information in and you need to be able
to to process it you have to really
think about it if you just take whatever
information is thrown at you you guys
are in the informatics program you guys
know the difference between data and
information yeah I mean data is just
data I mean it bits and bytes it's just
stuff that kind of gets flung at you
information is something usable
something that you can actually do
something with and you have to convert
this huge flood of data that you can get
from everybody out there that you're
working with into usable information and
that requires a lot of thought process
as well and then even more importantly
the other thing is you have to be
motivated and you have to take action
and you're going to have to do when you
don't have enough information you know
as it's it's one of the scariest things
about being an entrepreneur and raise
your hands again who'd started a
business oh yeah so I mean when's the
last thing we had all the information
you're in a business of your own you had
all the information you wanted to to
make a decision I don't know if I can
remember the last time that happened for
me I mean and you get more information
in larger organizations which is great
also as an entrepreneur I think even
more so you have to be willing to take
those actions and then adjust as well
you have to be constantly coming back to
that same full cycle that whole thing is
iterative that we just went through you
know after you've taken that action then
you need to be curious and you need to
really open minded Lee look and
understand what it is that how did that
impact was a right you form hypothesis
you execute on that you test it and you
have to listen and understand they have
to be curious yeah to listen think you
have to act you keep doing that cycle
over and over again and they're pretty
small circles you have to be iterating
pretty quickly around that another
reason not to be an entrepreneur really
quickly it is is the money don't don't
do it for that
and now that doesn't vote shoot it's
skipped forward on me there I was going
to talk about this forty-eight percent
actually of gdp is actually generated
through small businesses twenty or
twenty employees are smaller so there's
a huge impact that entrepreneurs also
can have in that process another
perspective around this is job creation
sixty-three percent of new jobs in the
last 15 years were created through
entrepreneurship and then another one
eighty-nine percent eighty-nine percent
of total employment is in across the
country not new jobs the total
employment is actually in companies 20
or smaller so you know there's a huge
impact that you can have through that
entire process and I kind of suggested
this earlier but a hundred percent of
jobs ever created were started by
entrepreneurs every single company out
there somebody had to be entrepreneurial
somebody had to say I have this cool
idea for GE or IBM and I'm going to make
GE or IBM or epic or write MD or
whatever it is that you're creating
every single job out there whether
they're doing it for themselves whether
they're doing is a company and employing
other people it's a really it's it's
hugely important and impactful the last
couple things i'll say about
entrepreneurship is that you also all of
those things are really good and they're
good reasons to be an entrepreneur and
the impact that you can have you also
really do have to be an optimist and i
don't mean to be overly sunny I
generally think of myself as a bit of a
pragmatist which is not the opposite by
any means of an optimist but optimism is
really important and you're going to
have a ton of people if you're in an
entrepreneurial environment tell you
this isn't going to work you really
ought to go do something else and this
is going to fail and the thing is you
have
maintain optimism through that process
but the sad thing is there right there
right when they say that eighty percent
of new companies fail in the first 18
months and they know that's part of that
same iteration process and you kind of
have to be okay with it or at least not
pay attention to it you know if this is
if poker is a good analogy for
entrepreneurship actually I don't know
how many how many people play poker in
here wake up you fool okay so there's
kind of there's two ways you can see
people play poker and we could talk
about which one is more successful you
can play each hand and you can try and
win the most hands possible right
generally not a particularly successful
strategy at poker or you can play a lot
of hands but play them really small and
wait for a winning hand and then play
that winning hand really big and I would
encourage anybody who is interested in
entrepreneurship to take that second
approach to their business processes as
well as their poker play that makes
sense you're going to fail I mean there
will be failures in that process the
question I tell everybody they don't
mind failing I just don't like repeating
the same mistakes twice I think that's a
really good thing to be able to take
away from it so that's entrepreneurship
as a whole I could tell you guys a
little bit about me although I hate
talking about myself I probably ought to
fit that in there someplace I think
pfizer you'd asked me to do this so i
will be nice and i will do that so my
background I am a physician by training
and and and by practice although i would
say that i'm an entrepreneur at heart i
started my first business at 17 because
i really didn't know what else did you I
actually kind of fell into it and I had
an opportunity to be able to do
something that worked out nicely i
actually did real estate investment and
is very different than healthcare and if
you guys are interested in real estate
investment and development you can ping
me some time and I will tell you about
why I left but it largely has to do with
the same thing i was mentioning earlier
people are in health care because they
want to do good they want to make things
better in spite of incentives generally
i won't say this about everybody there's
always a bell curve in any space but in
real estate folks are in it because they
want to make a bunch of money and that's
all right but I really did want to be in
something different and so I had that
opportunity to be able to look around
and see what was out there and really
realized that health care was it was the
right space for me to be in it was a
calling I'm more of a vocation and so I
went I went to med school and came up
here for residency and in the process of
seeing patients I was realizing a couple
of things one I missed entrepreneurship
it's a different kind of thinking how
many clinicians do we have in the room
all right cool we got clinicians to
that's good and I think I I personally
really their pieces I don't practice and
they're pieces of clinical practice that
I miss I miss you know being able to
walk into a room and an instantly
developer for with a patient you know
ask him anything he can ask them how
many times can you walk in a room ask
somebody to take off their underwear and
tell you about their drug habits and
they do it and thank you for it I'm him
and and you actually did them good in
the process that's really neat exciting
stuff but I kind of realized that a lot
of the patients that I saw they were
they were sick in part because of the
same issues that we saw at the beginning
of the presentation you know the system
was broken they can't get access to care
were 38 or older at the bottom of the
pile of development in terms of our
ability to be able to effectively
deliver care to people and I wanted to
do something with that combination of
skills with my clinical expertise and my
business experience and my ability be
able to think about things that way
there
they could have that broader impact and
be able to make things better not one
patient at a time but kind of a cross a
system and so there's a funny thing that
happens when you get an MD your clinical
credibility goes way up that's probably
not surprising interestingly enough and
unfortunately for many situations your
your business credibility tends to go
down and that's unfortunate but but true
so I did go back and get my MBA to kind
of let people know that I actually can't
think about things from a business
perspective and then worked at
Providence for about five years did some
consulting work in there too but worked
at Providence about five years it was
medical director and helped lead product
strategy and that's a funny word in
healthcare you guys what do you guys
know anybody familiar with product
strategy as a limited number of hands
but that's good I'm glad we get at least
one up that's good in a very nutshell
version and again if you guys are
interested I think it's hugely if you
can bring a product mindset to whatever
it is that you do I think it's a really
powerful thing and not only an
entrepreneurship neighbor how am I
solving people's problems I mean it's a
very limited function of that I mean
like I said you could talk a bunch about
what a product mindset is but really how
do i what is the problem people are
trying to solve and how can I best do
that it's kind of the tenant that you
could build project around and that was
kind of what I did for Providence I
thought about clinical strategies how do
we bundle care services in a way that
better meets people's needs helps them
actually solve their problem nobody
actually wants a hip replacement what
they want is to not have hip pain that's
kind of the problem that you're trying
to solve and so how can we better meet
that need you know how do we build
digital products to help people
understand their options shared
decision-making tools and portal tools
help them understand cost and solve some
of those same problems that we're seeing
at the beginning of this of the
presentation as well so how do we build
those how do we bundle things
differently and that was interesting and
very exciting and but eventually at some
point I realized they could really want
to get back
internship and do snow balls instead of
glaciers so that's kind of the short
version on me well kind of mid-sized
version on me and I was going to tell
you guys a little bit about the specific
company that I'm doing now which is
Right MD but again i'll pause for a
second see you guys got any questions or
comments I must be walking it today all
right all right we'll do the company
bright md so we talked about some of the
same problems primary care access and i
put those slides i focus on that area in
the early part of the presentation
because i do think that it's really a
pain point and i think it's going to get
a lot worse before it gets better and
it's part of what we do around right md
so think about the experience that
patients have you know they they have
low acuity conditions that come up they
make up sixty percent of the visit
volume that comes into primary care ear
aches and rashes and sore throats coughs
colds flus seasonal allergies UTIs and
makes up sixty percent of visible and
that comes into primary care and that
consumes a tremendous amount of time and
it makes up about forty percent of
primary care spend and then they call up
when they've got one of those conditions
because that's what they've been trained
to do and they they called their primary
care provider and they say hey I've got
one of these conditions can you get me
in to get seen and then you get saw that
map you guys remember the map of the
United States with those big big numbers
on there about wait times that's what
they hear which doesn't make them very
happy when you've got a kid with with
the cult with a cough that's keeping
them up all night or you've got an itchy
uncomfortable rash or a burning UTI you
want care yesterday not 66 days from now
and so what they get that message when
they called their primary care providers
office and that kind of doesn't make
them very happy so what we've done is
we've actually built the platform that
we licensed to delivery systems and for
me I'm going to talk a little bit my
philosophy behind the business there are
there other companies out there who are
looking to kind of disrupt the
healthcare delivery system and be
delivery systems they kind of want to
siphon off
these low acuity visits from existing
primary care providers and take care of
them virtually you know they hire Docs
and they like come over here because
your doc can't take care of you quick
enough so come on over here and we'll
take care of you faster and you know
it'll cost you it'll cost you a little
bit less and we really don't want to do
that we really believe that care
delivery is better with your primary
care provider with that continuity and
with the relationship that you have but
we also think that it is better to work
smarter than harder you know this think
about the agricultural revolution you
know I mean we get this explosion of
population and we need to feed more
people and you can either throw more
farmers at it with picks and shovels or
you can build the tractor right I mean
that's yeah and it's kind of the same
thing what we're doing right now is
we've seen this explosion of demand for
primary care services and what do we do
is we we're going to train more
providers we're going to throw more
bodies at it and we're going to whip
them to go a little bit faster and what
we're trying to do instead is help them
work smarter so they can point their
patients towards this online service
that they staff and the patients go on
in the answer set of branching logic
adaptive clinical questions really
thorough think about kind of a virtual
physician assistants of sorts where we
really can be incredibly thorough we
asked them all these questions and get a
really complete interview from them
askim preferences we actually even bacon
clinical logic where if you answer set
of questions in a way that makes you a
higher risk patient you know you've got
sore throat but you've got fever and
you've got it you have a hard time
swallowing food and you've had it for
extended period of time well maybe
that's a peritonsillar abscess we've
brought to bring that in probably not
still but we know we escalate a pretty
decent chunk of people but maybe ten
percent of visits we escalate through
that process you know and and that's
just purely based on the algorithms in a
logic that are baked them for the tool
assuming you make it through there we
bundle up all of those all that
information and we present it to
providers in a really easy-to-use format
so instead of spending 20 minutes that's
what it takes on average about 15 to 20
minutes for a primary care provider to
interview
evaluate diagnose prescribe document
they'll do the whole schtick that's what
it takes is about 20 minutes of primary
care provider time as soon as we take on
all of that information and we put it
into a format that's incredibly easy for
them to be able to use because it take
out all of the waste we had one of our
clients call us the ultimate lean for
primary care you guys do leme miss ya so
I mean the idea is just why ask that
question why why are we doing this this
way or you know is it is it really the
most efficient effective way to be able
to do it and so that's what we've done
you know you can see I'll point out a
couple of quick features I'm not if I
features matter less than the value that
they create but you know we have
diagnosis up there they actually have
you can see that's a drop-down you have
a differential there that you can change
it from you've got treatment options
patient education we write the chart
note for the providers because you know
especially when these low acuity
conditions with chart notes they're
algorithmic they're predictable and
again if there's clinicians out there
who want to debate this I'm totally open
to talking about it but we've heard a
really fantastic response around this I
mean the charting rate that happens now
is not because it's what I need for
clinical care is because what I need to
do in order to get paid and so we can
help with that process and make it
smoother and more streamlined and let
providers focus on top of licensed
practice free them up so now instead of
taking 15 to 20 minutes takes about 90
seconds to 2 minutes to be able to
complete an exam which means that
providers can spend more time with those
complex patients those people those
diabetics who have got congestive heart
failure and COPD and a foot ulcer and
they're going to wind up in the hospital
if they don't get more care outpatient
but they're still getting fit in think
about a provider's work day you get to
see an ingrown toenail and you get a 20
minutes lot of time do we'll take care
of that and then you see that diabetic
with a foot ulcer and COPD and
congestive heart failure and they get a
fit him into a 20-minute slot and that's
really not the way that it ought to be
so what we're trying to do is say okay
you know we've really created that
process historically where we we create
schedule slots and we fit patients and
regardless of whether that's where they
ought to be or not we're saying for
these low acuity conditions let's make
those really simple to give you
time to be able to spend with those
other folks free up your time to
practice again at top of license I could
talk about the economics around this as
well I don't know how much interest you
guys have but quick show of hands I can
skip through that stuff really fast or I
can dive into it who wants to hear more
about kind of the value we end up look
at was a decent number of hands I want
to the other side of it okay so if you
think about that we do the first thing
that we do around this is we help drive
down the cost per unit of care
traditionally healthcare delivery for
these low acuity conditions 992 and 299
2 & 3 mix they cost about 80 bucks to
deliver a unit of care that's mgma
numbers that's pretty well established
that's pretty well stat was that doesn't
mean that that's what every health care
delivery system costs and many large
integrated healthcare delivery systems
in fact they cost a lot more per unit of
care to deliver it and they're okay with
that they actually lose money on primary
care because they're going to make money
on filling hospital beds in their
primary care is their channel be able to
fill those hospital beds and they're
okay doing that but on average cost 80
bucks and they get reimbursed for the
same 992 and 299 2 & 3 mix at 85 bucks
of ism you're making as an organization
five dollars in margin for a 20 minute
visit which is not great but it's okay
now that doesn't Medicare Medicaid that
reimburses it like forty six dollars per
visit eighty dollars in costs you guys
can do the math that's not necessarily a
fantastic setting to be able to do that
in what we've done is we've taken all of
the incremental drivers of costs in in
health care we take in real estate
support staff physician time and we've
driven them all down by taking out some
of that waste it doesn't need to happen
and so the total cost per unit of hair
ends up being about 15 bucks per visit
which is great it's great for patients
because we've driven on the cost rate
for providers because now they actually
can make more margin on those visits and
they can actually get seen more quickly
and the nice thing is the payers like it
too because they can reimburse not at 85
per visit but II visits are reimbursing
at forty to sixty five dollars per visit
so you've driven down total cost
care so the system is actually costing
less providers are making more money
which means they they also can charge
patients less and they can get patients
seen more quickly that's that is our
goal is to drive that Triple Aim win you
improve outcomes you improve experience
and you drive down costs and that was
really our motivation around that but
again the other thing that we've done is
what used to be 20 minutes of time is
now two minutes of time and that's
really it's really powerful much more
valuable actually for everybody then
what we've done on that per visit basis
and I'll show you really quickly on an
annualized basis how we do this so you
hire a primary care provider as a
delivery system and you make about
seventy thousand dollars per year
annually so we went from a per visit
model to an annual model provider makes
for their organization but seventy
thousand dollars per year in margin
we're hearing these numbers 22 patients
a day or what providers are being now
pushed to see that's a lot of patients
but if they see 22 patients a day so
that sixty percent of patients are
eligible for we're talking about that
earlier we said okay we'll round down to
about 11 for patients out of those 11
who are eligible actually use the
service they're making more margin here
but the nice thing also though is we're
also more importantly those four visits
that used to take 80 minutes now they
take eight which means that you've got
more capacity and we saw the capacity
crunch that we were struggling with
earlier so it's not like you know it's
not like you're just sitting there with
an empty office you've got a 30-percent
shortfall in the ability to be able to
meet patient needs and that doesn't
include things like what else we're
asking providers to do like panel
management and coordination of care that
just assumes that every unit of care
ends up being the same size as it used
to be in the past so we're back filling
now and we're back filling with patients
who really need care and then you've
also got after-hours care and visits
that are happening there aren't very
efficient and you've got the downstream
revenue that you can make from your
hospitals but even more important this
is the part that I really like is that
we're making more capacity for patients
in need you know we're helping make sure
that we can spend that
with diabetics and with complex patients
patients with psychosocial challenges
and patients with complex care needs and
and the nice thing is that because of
those same shifts that we're talking
about moving from fee-for-service into a
value-based model the last place you
want to be spending your time and your
money is on air wakes and rashes and
sore throats you want to be spending
your time taking care of those patients
who really need to be in your office and
the neat thing is that in that model you
actually make money for doing it if you
coordinate that care and you keep those
patients out of the hospital and you
spend time not with the earrings with
the diabetics then you can actually
really extract even more value any more
importantly create more value through
that process as well so that's kind of
overview of bright md we've got a few
minutes here a bit kind of a stop on my
prattle up here and see what questions
you guys have and how I can help out so
we already know that bay area is very
favorable for startups and what kind of
opportunities like incubators receive
funds are here in oh my gosh there are
now 14 incubators two of which that are
starting up right now in Portland there
14 in computers total for startups
that's a ton and two of those 14 are
actually healthcare IT specific so there
is a ton of resources that are out there
to support this the Portland is a
fantastic market for two reasons one of
them is that is really put a lot of
focus towards entrepreneurship
specifically around software development
and an engineering but it's it's also
really less expensive than the bay the
technical term that people like to use
for that is capital efficient what that
means is you can raise less money and do
more for it and you are seeing an
increasing amount of money that is
available
and everybody sees the same problem that
you know the fact that we're spending
twenty percent of GDP that alone gets
investors really interested they say
there's two things that investor looks
for in a company one of them is the size
of the pond and the other one is the
quality of the fishermen and when the
spin worked hard in spin is a really
really big pond and like I said there's
an incredible incredibly target-rich
environment in health care and I think
people are recognizing that and so then
the question is you know how good of a
fisherman can you convince people to
other resources i would say we're
actually uniquely positioned in organ
specifically also we have an incredibly
progressive state government around
healthcare legislation we haven't in
pretty competitive one of arguably one
of the most competitive healthcare
environments in the country and we have
a ton of delivery systems we got a ton
of competing health plans not all
markets can say that so that really
helps also fuel all that we're leading
the country in a lot of ways there's a
ton of there's a ton of talent here from
a development standpoint thanks to
impart some of the work that you guys
are doing there's also a ton of
informatics and an EMR specific
technical talent that's here which is
relatively unique so either there's a
ton I could go on and lift a bunch of
reasons why I'm here and not there
besides it back to Portland is way
cooler than the bay but oh yeah what
else yeah I had a question you mentioned
that sixty percent of patients are
eligible meaning that their low acuity
and so that would kind of infer that
sixty percent of physicians are working
below the top of their license Oh much
more than that okay with this you know
with kind of the shift towards models
that you're talking about do you think
this is also going to fuel a shift in
the types of providers that are
these patients maybe increase of more
use of nurse practitioners example yeah
yeah no I I definitely think so in fact
we at this point what we've seen from
our clients I'm biased so I will not
talk about my thoughts on it but I from
what we've seen from our clients of
those who are working with mid-level
providers of the folks who should be
doing a lot of this care you know I mean
if we want to create the most value
possible you want to staff this you're
not staffing this with a cardiologist
you know I mean let's go to the other
extreme you're not going to you know
you're not going to get an orthopedic
surgeon to sit down and do these there's
no reason than you're doing that the
question is how can you help people give
them the tools to be able to operate at
the top of their particular license and
yes so I think mid-level practice is a
very important piece of it doesn't mean
that we don't give them tools to help
them work smarter I think it's a
combination of both of those its
staffing changes as well as operational
changes as well as the tools that we're
using to support them finance your
question okay yeah
so I have a couple of questions first
these how do you build your knowledge
base or how do you feed this organism
you prevail yeah so we are there is not
a set of compiled clinical data or
algorithms out there so we have to build
that there's there's algorithms out
there around things like diabetes cancer
care oddly enough there weren't
algorithms out there around Eureka now
that doesn't mean that there's not data
out there and peer-reviewed journal
articles and best practices and so it
done is we've aggregated those we have a
clinical review process and clinical
review board we also offer to all of our
our clinical partners as we call our
clients our clinical partners because we
really do partner with them we open that
up and we let them look at those
algorithms and give us feedback we don't
do custom algorithms and I think that's
actually a really important point you
know if you don't like the way we ask
you a question okay now if you have an
evidence-based reason you know we don't
think we know everything that section of
the thing I think I should have
mentioned that listening piece it'll
listen with an open mind as an
entrepreneur I definitely don't know
everything nobody's any stretch of the
imagination so you know we asked them
tell us if we've missed something let us
know what we've missed and give us the
information to support that that that
claim and we will bake that in and
children work towards building the very
best algorithm for everybody is that an
answer question just a follow-up yeah so
we've seen this happen in the media now
nowadays
maybe so what happens if your algorithm
makes a mistake or maybe a patient is
diagnosed with a flu and had something
else yeah yeah we've actually makin a
bunch of safety net processes around
that the most important pieces we are a
we gather information we organize the
information we present that information
to providers and we let them act on it
in a really efficient way but the
providers of the people who make that
decision we give them granular
information so that they they shouldn't
trust us in fact when we go in and we
talk with our clinic wire and I'm like
don't trust me please go in and look at
these you know you look at the questions
and look at the answer that are
available there we will earn your trust
by having the very best algorithms and
in fact we hear consistently from
providers in the four minutes of time
that they've got to interview a patient
they don't have anywhere near the
ability to be able to ask the 3270
questions that we do and throw our you
know we never we're never tired we never
forgot her a cup of coffee whenever
board were never rushed you know all
those things that happens because we're
human beings doesn't happen because it's
a computer and we have the person who is
the most engaged and the most interested
in in getting high quality health care
to the patient involved in that process
much more directly and so we actually
believe that by doing that being really
really thorough upfront and getting all
that information documenting it really
thoroughly and then providing it to
providers in a very transparent process
but also very easy to consume format we
can really help with that the other
thing we do is we set a really low
threshold for escalation so like I said
you know of the if we have a thousand
patients come in for sore throat one of
them's got a peritonsillar abscess maybe
or something else that's serious like
that we escalate 100 and that's fine is
anything we're still reading ninety
percent of patients with faster care
lower-cost care and with higher outcomes
because we can be more thorough in our
evaluation around that and we improve
the care for a loyal people we don't
have more time to be able to get it so
that's that's another piece that we do
there's a bunch of pieces and if you're
interested in the specifics around
how we do that with the product itself
I'd actually be happy to give you a
little demo sometimes as well questions
yeah so what are the different areas or
fields you feel that in health care are
ripe for how long do we have they all
are ya know they all are there's an
incredible amount of them I think we are
moving into a heard somebody talk about
this in the three phases of healthcare
we had the pre EMR phase of health care
where you know you had to have you know
three docs in the room and one of them
is transcribing the other ones writing
orders and another one's asking the
patient questions interviewing that did
happen I mean they're actually you know
that happened not that long ago like 50
years ago that was less than 50 years
ago that was happening we had the EMR
period where we're actually implementing
these EMRs and now we can actually do
things like measure look at quality and
look at a look at utilization and and
standardize some of that stuff and then
we've also got the post EMR phase now
which is where you start the EMR systems
are I believe likely to act as databases
almost operating systems if you think
about it but they're not going to be
able to keep up with the kind of
innovation that smaller companies are
going to be able to do layering on top
of that being able to use that data we
do that with right md you know we take
in medications allergies problem lists
labs all those pieces are information
that we can take and we can process that
and use that to help the providers
rather than having them go look it up
how do we ease their way how do we make
things move a little bit more smoothly I
think there is always room to continue
improving on quality and how do we
measure that again the definition around
that is a really important one I think I
really from my perspective the biggest
pain points that we hear taking that
project mindset what's the pain that
people are feeling right now and how can
we solve that better the things that we
hear are about that capacity and patient
access and provider burnout and the
inability to be able to shift from these
fee-for-service business models into
value based models
tools that can be built that do that
that help with any or all of those
pieces I would say are really really
high value right and i would say that
they're of all of the targets out there
those are the ones that are probably
highest value that help yeah I like I
said long list we could talk about the
granular pieces a lot more if you like
happy to